50% au tennis 50% de squash vous obtenez
le padel un sport de raquette opposant
deux équipes de deux joueurs
le but du jeu déstabiliser l'adversaire
dans les échanges pour marquer des
points
la particularité c'est qu'on est on
encore et par des parois en verre et du
coup on va avoir la possibilité en fait
de remettre la balle dans le court
adverse français dans du mur cette
activité attire beaucoup de joueurs de
tennis leucate d'elodie marais du club a
délaré nador on pourrait le tournoi
s'arrête en demi
ces deux tenniswomen poursuivre leurs
adaptations techniques du padel c'est
vraiment un sport qui est complémentaire
mais j'ai justement de la stratégie
c'était justement de ne jouer pas de
ralentir le jeu
et
et voilà s'amuser avec les vitres le
grillage avec ses anciens tennismen les
frères maigrir et représente le pet et
les clubs de bois d'arcy à
l'échauffement et préparent leur demi
finale
la victoire donne accès aux championnats
de france ils peuvent compter sur leur
complicité
voilà en tant que moi grand frère ça me
fait toujours plaisir de partager des
moments des bons moments comme des moins
bons de temps en temps aussi suivant les
résultats voilà dans dans un sport avec
lui on sait quand il faut s'encourager
on sait quand il faut quand il faut
essayer de motiver l'autre on sait quel
type de balle il va jouer donc ces
hausses automatiques on apprend on n'a
pas travaillé
qualifié en finale julien et adrien ont
ensuite remporté le tournoi ils sont
assurés de participer aux championnats
de france prévus à valenciennes les 22
23 et 24 septembre